channel 8 obtaining the arrest report  for the man police say killed three  people in north las vegas on monday joe  mohler live in our newsroom with the  very latest  tristan twidwell matched the description  that people gave at three different  crime scenes and was arrested not too  far from where they all happened police  say he also shot a dog  patrol officers found a gun in his bag  when they found him all the shootings  happened monday night in the area of  cheyenne and civic center according to  the police report he confessed to the  killings he was walking around from area  to area shooting three men and that dog  when officers asked why he did it he  reportedly told them it needed to be  done  according to the district attorney's  office tidwell has a lengthy criminal  record and was just released from jail  in july  tidwell has been booked on three counts  of open murder with a deadly weapon  reporting in the newsroom jim mueller 8  news now